[Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  i couldn't be happier with all the sweet  renders that came in from you guys  really made this montage special  if you want to see how i created my  piece definitely check out this video  here where i break down my entire  process  and i actually do a vfx live stream  every single saturday i documented the  entire process of  this whole render and if you're not  definitely subscribe so you guys don't  miss out on awesome  contests like this in the future pny and  nvidia  actually gave me some really really cool  pc hardware to send to the winners and  what do you guys think what do you guys  think are the best three renders but i  gotta run i gotta get to this vfx live  stream  i hope to see you guys there so we can  all learn and grow together my name is  clinton jones and i'll see you guys next  time  peace